La vraie raison de la séparation de Brad Pitt et Angelina a été dévoilée,
elle va vous étonner.
C'est vraiment étonnant.
Ce chaton aux yeux très gros va vous émouvoir aux larmes.
Il est trop mignon.
L'histoire de l'enfant abandonné qui a réussi dans la vie va vous redonner foi en l'humanité.
Ça va vraiment mieux.
Que la vie est belle.
Le récit poignant de ce tour du monde va vous donner envie de quitter votre job.
Je démissionne.
Regardez ce que cette femme fait pour son bébé prématuré.
Les bras m'en tombent, pas vous ?
Ah beh si.
Cet acrobate de rue est si doué qu'il va vous faire chier liquide par l'urètre.
Il est vraiment doué.
Ce discours d'un chômeur à un élu va vous choquer et vous donner envie de renverser la 5e République.